salah abdeslam is being held in the
floor he mahadji prison complex outside
paris he's the only known surviving
suspect in the paris attacks he's been
placed in isolation under video
surveillance monitored by guards skilled
in handling dangerous detainees his
extradition from belgium to france on
april twenty seventh this year was just
the beginning of a long and painstaking
investigation a French Court has
formally charged Abdeslam for murder
attempted murder hostage taking and
unlawful possession of weapons and
explosives his lawyers are not willing
to go on record about the ongoing
investigation but a few core questions
are clear what role did Abdeslam play in
Paris and Brussels what was his
responsibility in planning and carrying
out the attacks Abdeslam grew up in the
molenbeek area of Brussels and many
Belgians feel a degree of guilt it's
something they're still coming to terms
with how is he able to hide for so long
how does the state plan to prevent
further acts of terrorism in particular
the opposition are criticizing the
Liberal government for not taking
responsibility for Investigative
failures a fact-finding committee has
been established to bring clarity the
most urgent is the communication and the
sharing of information I think this is
crucial we have to work on that that
means that people have made have to
innovate invest in people who receive
information and give information
suspected terrorists will always be able
to find loopholes to slip through say
some politicians to them it's in the
nature of the Belgian state and
sometimes I fear we are in shock in this
country there's always been some
distrust of state authority unlike in
France or Germany oh my naughty car was
it I'm [ __ ] for Posada she only does
that be the interests of the different
cultures here I'm ripping this land
apart it has to do Chanel mean Lizzy
starter speed
abdeslam's lawyers fog Burton and spin
Maui have planned a strategy for their
client they will claim diminished
responsibility they want to show that
their client wasn't smart enough to have
planned the attacks that he was just a
follower Molly abdus lumps defense
lawyer said he's as intelligent as an
ashtray it will be months if not years
before the trial begins